قد يكون لظهور التكنولوجيا الرقمية
أحد أكثر التأثيرات عمقًا في
كيفية تعليم أطفالنا البرمجة
وصنع التكنولوجيا ، فقد أصبحت مثل
القراءة والكتابة والحساب
وطريقة أخرى للتعبير عن نفسك
في العالم الحديث والألعاب
والأدوات التي تساعدهم  تعلم هذه
المهارات أصبحت متقدمة بشكل متزايد وتم
تقديمها لهم في وقت مبكر جدًا ،
يُطلق على هذا الروبوت الخشبي اسم cubetto ، وقد تم
تصميمه لتعليم الأطفال الذين تقل أعمارهم عن
ثلاث سنوات البرمجة بشكل أفضل وهو
روبوت خشبي يمكن للأطفال توجيهه
خلال مغامرة باستخدام الكتل
بدلاً من الكود  لقد استبدلنا الكود
الذي عادة ما يكون موجودًا على الشاشة
بكتل بسيطة جدًا تدخل داخل
لوحة ، ويمكن للأطفال إنشاء هذه
التسلسلات من التعليمات التي توجه
الروبوت بشكل أفضل من النقطة أ إلى النقطة
ب دون أن يعرفوا
أنهم يبلغون من العمر ثلاث سنوات.
كتبوا السطر الأول من الكود وقد
فعلوا ذلك باستخدام لغة
يفهمونها بالفعل في الحضانة ، لذا
فإن  لن يبدأ الأطفال البالغون من العمر ثلاث سنوات في
اختراق أنظمة الكمبيوتر
حتى الآن ، لكن الألعاب مثل هذه يمكن أن تمنحهم أساسًا
متعدد الاستخدامات في لغة
الترميز ، إنها مهارة يمكنك تطبيقها
على أي شيء تتعلمه بشكل أساسي عن التفكير
في  الأسلوب المنطقي
والعقلاني يهدف كانو إلى ربط الأطفال بشكل
أعمق بالتكنولوجيا من خلال تقديم
شاشات الكمبيوتر والكاميرات التي
يمكن للأطفال بناء أنفسهم بها ، ما هي
أفضل طريقة ليكونوا مشاركين في
التكنولوجيا في حياتك من
صنعها وترميزها والتحدث بلغتها
تتعاون الشركة مع المدارس
والحكومات لجعل
تعليم الكمبيوتر ممتعًا حتى لو كانت لعبة ما نهدف إلى
القيام به في cammo حيث أن أفضل ألعاب الفيديو
تهدف إلى تحديك بشكل مناسب ،
لذا فإن بناء شيء ما يمثل تحديًا على غرار ليغو
ولكن طالما لديك
دليل خطوة بخطوة ستستمتع به في
كتابة شيء ما هو إتقان أسلوب Zelda
والتحكم
لن يتم فتحه ببساطة من قبل
مدرس مدرسة يثقبك مع
صديق سابق  كتاب تمرين أو كتاب مدرسي بطول 400
صفحة حول برمجة صفحات الويب
بلغة بايثون ، يجب أن يتم غرسه في
سن مبكرة ويجب أن يكون شيئًا
ممتعًا
ولا يقتصر تطبيق Ventris على واجبات منزلية فحسب ، لذا
احضر الأشياء التي يحبها الأطفال بالفعل في
الفصل الدراسي واستخدمها في  تدريس
المواد الكلاسيكية
[موسيقى]